.
THE TOR.
RIGHT NOW THE COUNCITI FORMS  AS
COME SOON ENOUGH
AMERICANS ARE  TN ERICANEAD YES
DEESPANDEMICN.
2,0 E
HOIZED, YET ANOTHER
HAUNTING RECORD.
U.S. ICK TO ADD 1 HESTMAS HOLID.
N NEW  LESS THAN 7
THE O AUTHORIZE A SECONDRONAVIR.
AN FDA COMMITTEE IS MEETINOW ANB
CAE HOUSIN IT COULD ADD ON  THEL
>>ORMMERING T NDOT.
NDPACKAGBE ABLE TO PASS BOTH
RTISAN
MAES
MIO COIN THE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE WIL
RICHARD QUEST.T ITOW W
YOU KNOW, ARD, WE
INOW ABOUT WO BE
OR WANTED BY ESIDE.HAT ISG  IS Y
BILLION, BUT AT THE EN
STILUS CHECKS TO AMERICANS
BE PAR
W0 LIKE THE ISOMEWHER IT E SOME
THAT INS A NUMBER ONE
PR
BUT MORE CONTROVERSI WHEN YO
MOS .
IT SEEMS LIKELY THAT $A
WEEK EXTENSION OF THNEFITSD  $6
VERY IMPORTANT EVICTN MORATORIUL
TH BIPARTISAN, THAT IS CONSIDER
TOUCAND THEN YOUAV LIKE
NSTHE
EDUCATSE
TW- LET'GO
TO THE TWO THINGS THEA
HAVE BEENG POIS.
STATE AND LOCAL AI
THAT, SO THEY WILLE
THAT.OTOF ANOTHER DHI REA AG TA
T IS A BIGL,900
BILLION, BUT THETHTION IS,
EN HO GET AMERICANS
THHER SIDE OF NS?FEWS
QUESTION TO ANSWER.
L BE BACK AND E OF THE REACHL T.
IBN  IS NO AWASTORE,HE IS KEEPIS
E.D  VACCIGOT TO GET TO TH
WHERE THE COUNTRY ISVACCED
THAT IS ATWE'RE STILL TALKT SOCD
U TALKEDT BEINOUSLY AID TO THEM
TOGETHER.
L  BE?AUTHORITY, L
REON.
THEY WILL HAVERROW I
SS THE F IT I
IS CONGRESS
AND THE SENATE'T DO THAT
YE YOUR T RUNNIND S AREN'T
L COMMUNITY S OSED.
PHINGS RSRICHARD, THANK YOU.AT
DEY RIGHT MYGUEST, HIS HOSPITAL
E SOME
T VACCINSES ANIT
SERVES A PREDOMINANTLYN
MIOF TING IN GEORGE
>> YES.O.
>> GEORGE, TELL US ABOUT TS
EXPERIENCE
>> WELL, THIIS WONDERFUL
WEED T
FIRSY RECEE VACCINATIONS.I'D AL
R F ERR AND
STERING THE VACCINATION ON MY SI
IEMACISTPAL.LSO HAVE OUR CHIEF
NURSING OFFICER
>> SO I THINE
ALREADY GONE -WED NE IT WILL B
EEHIY TOINTY THERE.
AL GETTINGLITTLEIT IS SO IMPORTE
THIS
>> AND TWO VERY IMPORTANT
ISUNFORTUNATELY, AFRICAN-ARICANE
POPULATION HAVE RECEIVED DOUBLTH
ACROSS AMERICA, WE MAKE UP
DOUBOUR
PO
SO THE ONLY SOLUTION WE BELIEVE
IS A VACCINATION
SO WE'REFUTH NOW
HERE.
E THE FIRST HOSPITAL IN
CHICAGO  IT.BUT OUR TEAM MEMBERS
MAKE SURAT THE TO GET
TAKE CARE O                  NI
RUS VAIN IS A CONCERN OF
I WONDER AS WE HAVE SEENORE
TINGNDTHERE HAVE BEEN PEOP SPPU
GETTING THE VACCINE?
OF THOSE
CONCERNS.
AND WHAT WE DI AN
EXAMPLE, WE TOWN HL
G AM
MEMBERS AND LE ESTIONS TO BRING
VACCINATION WAS DEVELOPEAN
THE KEY NOTE HERE O
THNEE PREMIERESCIET H WA
AFRICAN-AMER.
CORBETT, WHOVE
VACCINATION ANE VERY
OU
THERE IS LEGITIMATE DISTRUST
T-CELL TPPENED IN THE T THIS ISE
THAT I
NTED TT AS A IT IS COMFBL VACCIN
HELP E PROBLEMSEE100 MILLION AO
HA TCC W
OF OUR TEAM MEMBERS ARE WILLING
IOTEY
CLEARLY THAT IT IS THE RIGTHING
IT HAS BE COMITHATETHING
THAT BRINGS YOPEVEING THROUGH T
VERYFI THE FRO